The basic HTML for grabbing the canvas object is pretty straightforward. We've
seen this before. The interesting thing that we haven't yet covered is grabbing
the context of the canvas. Think of the canvas object that we fetched from the
DOM as a DOM element. While the context is a handle to the drawing APIs that
we'll be able to use to modify the canvas visuals later. In this simple example,
we set the width and height to 1200 by 720 respectively. Now, it's worth
pointing out, that any time the user would resize the screen, the canvas will
remain this size. For the purposes of GRITS, we actually use the
window.innerwidth and window innerheight. sizes for our canvas, allowing it to
occupy the fullscreen for the user.